I will explain later in this video but
man on more than a few occasions I got
really hungry so Hannibal was the series
on NBC and it was essentially a show in
the Thomas Harris world yeah be the
world of Red Dragons Silence of the
Lambs Hannibal Hannibal Rising well at
least yeah never read the books but no
one likes the movie point is this show
took place before Silence of the Lambs
before red dragon for the most part it's
Hannibal Lecter when he's still dr.
Lecter he's revered he's a forensic
psychiatrist FBI profiler will Graham
he's looking for baddies and he's
consulting aníbal Lecter I'm not doing
it justice I'm just trying to keep it
vague enough point is this is a
wonderful and beautiful captivating
plummet into madness I enjoyed the first
two seasons of this tumble down the
rabbit hole of psychosis I hadn't seen
season three but now it's on Netflix and
I watched it and I thought two things
one why didn't i watch season three
earlier and two it is a crime that the
show is cancelled so let me talk about
what works in here first of all will
Graham will Graham yes the same
character played by Edward Norton and
red dragon he's not the first will
Graham we've had but if all the will
Graham's I've seen Edward Norton's
probably my least favorite not that
Edward Norton's a bad actor he's a great
actor I think he could have done an
amazing will Graham but for red dragon I
was just felt like he was a guy he was
good at his job no it's just he's good
at his job that's cool you can have
Harvey Keitel tell the audience all you
want that all has this extra thing is
this other thing that people don't have
but I never felt that way will Graham in
the series Hannibal he's not okay this
dude is so good at getting in the mind
of serial killers because he is kind of
one step away from that you really feel
like if his life had zigged instead of
zagged he probably would have become a
serial killer turns out he's an FBI
profiler when someone is so close to
madness but trying to hold on to their
sanity that's tough enough but when you
have Hannibal Lecter this captivating
figure with such a strong gravitational
force an apex predator both
psychologically and physically it's not
going to be held
Seifer will Graham and so it's the
dynamic there that's the main draw of
this show and because you're seeing it
through will Graham's eyes and will
Graham is kind of falling down the
precipice of madness for a large part of
this show you have this person who's not
mentally okay taking you along the ride
and I just have more fun with that when
we'll Granberry creates a crime scene in
this series he experiences it it shows
him committing the crimes as he's
mentally recreating them and because
he's our eyes our vessel through the
series and he's experiencing it that
means that's right we experience it I
mean as much as you can in a series
anyway
which means when he starts mentally
breaking down you feel it you understand
it the show is like a psychological
theme park ride a roller coaster bungee
jump the reason we go on those rides
because it gives us all the thrill of
danger without actually putting us in
danger this is all the thrill of seeing
madness without the danger of going mad
that's what Hannibal is in in a nutshell
and there's something captivating about
that something beautiful about the show
this show has amazing imagery the way it
shows how the insane people in this show
whether it be Willa Graham at some of
his darkest moments or other characters
it shows what they see how they see the
world it's twisted dark [ __ ] also the
show is graphic as hell in terms of
violence I was amazed that this show
actually aired on NBC maybe that's why
it was canceled people are like Oh NBC
whoa the kids are still up we can't
watch this right now we're gonna wait
till they go to bed and those Hannibal
was cancelled making it one of the great
tragedies of television no no I know
this show has a cult following I don't
know how the masses see the show I don't
know how fans are the books view the
show I just know I really [ __ ] liked
it and some of the storytelling is a
little shuffled around from what I know
the story to be again just saw the
movies never read the book so maybe the
movies took liberties maybe they took
things that happened way before and they
put that in Hannibal but there are
things that happen in the movie Hannibal
that take place before red dragon
certain things were I know the fate of
other people in movies that happen
differently and it just kind of takes
liberties that way but as long as you
keep the essence of the characters it's
fine and this show it does a great job
at that all the acting is great -
Laurence Fishburne is Jack Crawford Hugh
Dancy is will Graham and that
brings us to Mads Mikkelsen as Hannibal
Lecter here's the thing Anthony Hopkins
made Hannibal Lecter Hannibal Lecter
again was not the first actor to portray
Hannibal Lecter on screen that was
actually Brian Cox but when you have Sir
Anthony Hopkins taking home a Best Actor
Oscar for just 15 minutes of screen time
in a movie that perfectly merged the
genres of horror psychological thriller
that's Hannibal Lecter now so in a world
where Hannibal Lecter is not too
dissimilar to the Joker in terms of what
I'm going to touch on here Joker and
Hannibal Lecter are both mythical
characters in terms of cinematic
antagonists in that recasting or casting
for a different take gives people that
whoa what are you doing kind of visceral
reaction or at least we'll call it a
limbic response he does do really well
because he does what actors do should do
which is don't try to emulate the other
guy make it your own in Mads Mikkelsen
does his own Hannibal Lecter and he is
magnetic I think part of the reason I
had so much fun watching Mads Mikkelsen
be Hannibal Lecter's because the mask is
still on you know when we see Anthony
Hopkins for the first time in Silence of
the Lambs the mask is off like he's
caught everyone knows who Hannibal
Lecter is and what he's done so he's not
hiding anything but Mads Mikkelsen
Hannibal Lecter is wiring the mask
working with the FBI
the logistics change it evolve as the
show goes on as should happen in a
series but still that played into my
initial fascination with Hannibal also
killing and eating people which those
meals man five star Michelin star
cuisine I was hungry every time I know
they're supposed to be people but they
looked amazing just in terms of
production who do they have back there
making these meals for the shows do they
have chef geese evoi back there I don't
know man I just I cut my leg off and
cook it I'll eat it if it looks like
that it's just so boss seeing Hannibal
Lecter in a three-piece suit and an
apron cooking and he's just he's so
elegant elegant eloquent he's all of it
but in him being Hannibal the cannibal
also working with the FBI also
psychological
messing with people like he's pulling
will Graham towards him because he sees
who will Graham is and will Graham is
good at sniffing out serial killers
himself Hannibal knows that so he has a
show will Graham enough to entice him
but not so much that he freaks them out
and blows his cover and in that you have
one of the best psychological
cat-and-mouse games you've seen on
screen and really to its root the show
is about human connection you know the
connection between will Graham and
Hannibal Lecter this show does a great
job showing how cold Hannibal Lecter is
also does an amazing job at showing his
mindset at a capacity that really the
movies couldn't do is there are a lot
more hours you get with Hannibal Lecter
here than you ever got to have with the
movies and the show makes me really want
to read the books forgot what I was
gonna say to be honest with you I start
gushing about Hannibal Lecter I had a
point I was gonna make and just turning
into oh yeah human connection that's why
we do jump cuts my friends but it is
about human connection it shows that to
our root all of us we strive for that a
lot of what we do in the world is to
find human connection like if our two
scenarios want to have scenario a where
I make videos I upload them on to
YouTube and you all watch it I'd you
know Google Adsense and that pays for
the whole party or here's scenario B I
do the same thing upload them into some
vault that no one will ever see and
somehow Google pays me the same amount
of Adsense I would get paid if I upload
it onto YouTube difference is no one
would ever see my stuff I probably still
do YouTube because there's that there is
that human connection there which is
fascinating if I really do ponder that
it's like why why do we strive for that
I don't know but I like the fact that
even Hannibal Lecter isn't above it and
it also goes for will Graham the one
person who could really understand will
Graham is Hannibal Lecter is that
healthy not at all but it's what will
Graham wants the one thing I started
running into is when it starts to get to
the point where you start hearing lines
from Mads Mikkelsen Hannibal Lecter that
you have heard Anthony Hopkins Hannibal
Lecter also say now Mads Mikkelsen
saying it I can't help but be like but I
like how Anthony Hopkins delivered that
so for the most part Mads Mikkelsen
opened my eyes to the fact that other
people can be Hannibal Lecter like other
people can be the Joker and that person
can do an amazing
about it can make it their own as long
as the actors given the freedom to do
that
it seems that I'll be fans ever since
Netflix was like hey we have Hannibal
now fans were like oh this season for
happening it's gotta be right I don't
know but that would be great I think
that'd be amazing I think they should
try to do a season four on Netflix we've
seen from Lucifer that a show can find
life a show that's been canceled can
find new life on Netflix and season four
of Lucifer in my opinions the best
season of Lucifer and now there's
another season happening so who knows I
think that would be a great thing if
Netflix takes Hannibal if everyone's
able to come back to it I'd love to see
it but the three seasons that they have
right now do work as its own thing like
if you want to see the end of season
three as the conclusion it does work in
that capacity so I just finished
watching Hannibal I was gonna do Khan
air today but I was like yeah I really
want to talk about Hannibal you know if
I watched something I liked and I think
you'll like I'll bring it to your
attention I think Hannibal is great if
you're looking for a thrilling and
frightening ride into madness it's dark
it's [ __ ] up if that's your thing
you're welcome alright so Hannibal have
you seen it what did you think about it
would you like to see a season four on
Netflix or whoever can pick it up and
also I hear about the cult following of
people who like the show but did you not
like the show or you a fan of the books
or just like nod don't like how they did
the show and if so why we're here for
conversations that's the fun of the
Internet you know that human connection
thing us talking about whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]